this week on brian ross investigates
suppressing the vote huge numbers of
americans
wrongly removed from voter registration
lists
it bothers me it bothers me to my
core we're joined by the investigative
reporter
greg palast sounding the alarm about
trouble ahead
on election day sir why do we have to
sue you to get the
to get the names of voters who've been
removed plus inside the secrets of the
royal kingdom of saudi arabia
the insane spending sprees yachts
palaces
priceless works of art it's 400 million
is the bid
and the piece is sold
the crackdown on dissent and the
decision to kill the dissident and
washington post reporter
jamal khashoggi and the cozy
relationship
with president trump how important is it
to mbs that donald trump
be re-elected i think it's tremendously
important
and our winners and losers this week in
the media
see if you agree with the editors of
mediatek
do you not have an answer i just want to
be clear i know i again
yes or no do you have an answer and if
you don't
about very important issues from the law
and crime
trial network this is brian ross
investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook
live i'm brian ross joined as always by
my colleague at long crime ronda
schwartz
and ronda we're now three weeks away
from the national election it's fast
approaching
with great uncertainty as to whether we
can trust the outcome
the president with almost no evidence to
back him up claims widespread fraud is
likely with mail-in ballots
and democrats are saying that
republicans are working hard
to make it hard for voters to actually
cast their ballots
early voting is already underway in more
than 20 states that's almost half the
country
with six and a half million americans
have already voted in this year's
presidential election
that's ten times more than the usual
numbers at this time
according to one analysis and
everybody's on the alert for glitches
and problems
and no one is watching this more closely
rhonda than investigative reporter and
watchdog greg palace who's been
reporting on efforts
to wrongly remove voters from voter
rolls so they can't vote
thousands of wisconsin voters will be
removed from the state's voter registry
following the ruling of an ozaukee
county judge wisconsin's republicans
are demanding the state remove 153
000 citizens from its voter rolls that's
seven times
trump's 2016 victory margin and i don't
know why
it is that we have pastor greg lewis we
are so adamant
about making sure that we take
people off the registration role how can
we
come to this point where there's no love
at all
for a whole group of people who are not
going to understand when they go to vote
while they're getting hassled we spoke
to one of those targeted
sequana taylor found out last week that
i was on the purge this through my
office but did she move from milwaukee
seems unlikely okay so what are your
positions here yep so milwaukee county
supervisor district 2
and school board director district 3.
from milwaukee wisconsin this is greg
palast reporting
and so we're now joined by greg palace
speaking from los angeles
greg good evening to you give us an idea
exactly how this works as i understand
it
people with common names are being
kicked off their voter registration
polls
well there's two things one uh there's
you have common names so example
michigan was removing hundreds of voters
literally named michael brown
and michael jackson uh and james brown
but james thomas brown who is registered
in atlanta
is removed because means edward brown
is registered in detroit they say oh
it's two james browns they must be the
same person
so you have that craziness plus you just
saw shauna taylor
she is milwaukee county supervisor and
she was removed because they said she
left milwaukee now if you
you can't vote if you in milwaukee if
you love milwaukee but she's a
supervisor
so i don't think she left so these so i
had experts go
through these lists and determine that
about
in wisconsin they're about a hundred and
uh about uh
nearly a hundred thousand people
identified as having moved from their
homes who didn't
they had a bad list and in michigan you
see some of the same things
and those long lines in georgia to a
great extent are because
a report i did for the aclu we uncovered
about 198
000 people wrongly identified as moving
so what happens is they sent in for
their mail-in ballots they don't get
them
and there they are they're waiting in
those long long lines because they never
got their mail about because they're no
longer on the voter rolls
so you do have this problem in several
states that we're covering
greg you've been at this for several
years now this same issue have you
stopped any of it you think or is it
still ongoing
oh yeah i mean i've been on it for 20
years but the state of wisconsin bless
them
when i showed them the evidence that
they had a massive number of illegally
uh purged voters voter who uh that
they're
targeting to remove the state board of
elections said no we're not going to use
this bad list
so the state board of elections actually
has gone into court to say the state
will
not remove these voters so that's a huge
win
we've also put up a site uh
savemyvote2020.org
where voters can see if they've been
purged and re-registered they're still a
week to re-register for example in
michigan
so you want to know if you are still on
the voter rolls i want everyone to check
their registration don't assume
that you're registered you don't
necessarily get a notice that you've
been removed
greg a question for you from rhonda
schwartz rhonda
what about president trump's claims that
there's going to be widespread fraud
with mail-in balloting
is there anything to back that up well
it's happened a couple times let's put
it this way i did a calculation based on
the studies from rutgers university
and the chance of you um
sending in a fraudulent mail-in ballot
uh is you're more likely by 527
to be hit and killed by lightning that's
how rare it is
so i don't worry about people sending in
fraudulent ballots what i worry about is
people
who are trying to get their ballots and
those ballots they'd never get them they
don't receive them on time because
they've been purged from the voter rolls
or someone challenges their ballot that
they've mailed in so a lot of
voters get defrauded by officials or
partisan uh
partisan poll watchers who may unfairly
challenge a boat i'm really worried
about that
and greg both sides seem to think
they're going to win
one side's going to lose and they're
obviously going to claim there was some
kind of fraud
what's going to happen uh the day after
the election or the week after the
election if there's still some
doubt about the outcome there's some
real problems here um we have to
remember we don't vote for the president
we vote for electors we have to
basically the states have to certify the
vote within
uh in florida by november 11th and say
who won
will they be able to count all the
mail-in ballots if there's massive
challenges
frankly if there's mayhem in some
polling stations as we saw in uh
in the year 2000 in the miami-dade
accounting office where the office had
to be shut down because people are going
crazy
we have to worry about that that states
will not be able to complete the ballot
count
by time they have to certify and send
members to the
electoral college remember they have to
certify in time for those people to
arrive by horseback in washington
it's a very old law
so are you concerned then about this
uncertainty
very much so what i'm worried about is
that some states literally
won't be able to certify their votes in
time they won't be able to get all the
ballots counted because there'll be so
many challenges
and so much uh accus and so many
accusations of fraud
that states state legislatures will
simply say
we can't pick a winner here we don't
have time we can't evaluate the ballots
that are challenged or we can't count
all the ballots
then if there's not 270 electoral votes
it goes to the house of representatives
and we might have for the first time in
american history
an amendment a 12th amendment election
that is the 12th amendment to the
constitution says
the electoral college can't pick someone
the house does
the house of representatives and that's
one vote for one state california and
south dakota
each get one vote it's going to be quite
a quite a battle all right well greg
palace stay on it
yes it will stay on it we're going to
get back to you great to talk to you
coming up inside the saudi royal family
the great secrets and the coziness with
president trump
you're watching the long crime trial
network
and now to a rare inside look into the
secretive royal family of saudi arabia
overseen by a new crown prince who
manages great wealth and people who have
committed murder rhonda
he's the 35 year old crown prince of the
kingdom of saudi arabia
muhammad bin salman more commonly known
by his initials
mbs brian we're joined now by justin
check and bradley hope
the authors of a great new book blood
and oil
mohammed bin salman's ruthless pursuit
of global power
thank you both for being here mbs as
he's known started off we thought as a
great reformer but
justin that's not the case well you know
i i think it's more complicated than
that i think he's someone who's intent
on
maintaining his power and his family's
power in saudi arabia and what he
believes that requires is having social
reforms to make the
country's young population of 60 of the
populations below 30
reforms to satisfy them but also
clamping down on dissent
making sure any threats to the royal
family are addressed and that includes
external threats like iran like qatar
where he's
been very aggressive the most prominent
target
dissident and washington post columnist
jamal khashoggi
saudi arabia confirms that the
journalist jamal khashoggi is dead
in jamal khashoggi entered the saudi
consulate in istanbul
and never came out after his death a
number of mbs
associates were convicted but not the
prince himself
well it's not hard for him to do that
because he is ultimately
you know him and his father are the
center of power so
he's taken the position that he he said
publicly it's my fault that this
happened but i didn't order the murder
he told them take care of this guy and
they
took it upon themselves to take care of
them as they saw fit and
it looks like you know from the sort of
the way things played out it looks like
they probably were
trying to kidnap him when they realized
that
would be inconvenient they you know
murdered and dismembered him
so they seem to be uh acting
on what they thought were his wishes
whether he explicitly said it or not
doesn't
really matter that much because they
were carrying out
something on his behalf you and bradley
have fascinating insights inside your
views of what's going on behind the
scenes there
including his uh acquisition of wealth
and uh
status symbols yachts arts tell me a bit
about that
well obviously um this is one of the
reasons why he had to fight so hard
against all of these rivals because when
you become the king of saudi arabia you
are immediately
uh you you have an overwhelming wealth
you know so you just
suddenly you get the biggest percentage
of the royal family's allocation of the
oil profits and you get access to all
kinds of other money as well
so very early on after all all this
wealth suddenly came into
both his father and his own control he
went on a kind of a spending spree
he um he had this crazy party in the
maldives
it was meant to last a month and he
rented it for rented out this hotel for
50 million dollars
brought all these people over 150 models
which we described in the book
and then he also bought this high-end
yacht the serene
you know famously his he he and his team
were flying over
uh i believe in the south of france and
they saw the pla they saw this boat and
they
decided to go take it for a spin and
then not that long after they bought it
sort of the asking price you know they
weren't there was no negotiation really
um and then also this immense chateau in
france
um that looks like it belongs to you
know
from the 17th centuries and he's also
justin uh sought some of the world's
most uh
priceless paintings these 400 million
dollars is the bid
and the piece is sold
even famously uh he was the mysterious
buyer of a of a
division what's most likely a da vinci
painting it was a the first you know
new davinci painting to be discovered or
unearthed in
you know many many years and it has its
own strange backstory but you know it
sold for this astonishing amount
and there was other speculation about
who the mystery buyer was and it turned
out to be
a sort of front buyer for him
uh given what he wants in terms of
global power
what has been his relationship with the
trump administration
well um really his cultivation
of the trump administration was both the
the key to his own
rise in power and it's it's the key to
his
ability to stay in power over these
periods of years and and
and sort of fend off all of these stats
to himself you know
so by the when by the time the donald
trump was first
elected um mbs still had some issues
about consolidating power and he
what he did was he used that he he
persuaded along with his team
the administration that it would be
worth their while to come to saudi
arabia for their first foreign trip
what what mbs wanted to do was to kind
of go
all out to impress trump and make trump
feel
not just welcome but honored and treated
as
uh you know a great statesman and an
international leader
and finally let me ask you how important
is it to mbs that donald trump
be re-elected i think it's tremendously
important
um you know he's really
staked a lot of a lot of his power on on
the relationship with america the uae
just recognized israel if saudi arabia
recognizes israel before the election
that that could be a foreign policy win
for trump
so i think there's a lot writing there
because if the democrats come in you
know when biden was vice president
um biden's foreign policy people and
obama's were
very skeptical of saudi arabia overall
and they expressed skepticism about the
war in yemen even though they assisted
with it in the early days
and there was you know obama was uh
constantly reminding them of human
rights issues um king salman felt that
hillary clinton was was lecturing him on
human rights issues
and so mbs especially really mistrusts
the democrats and
mistrusts their impulse to strike a deal
with iran
and you know it would be a real shift
and it could
you know cause saudi arabia to turn more
toward china or more toward you know
even even russia um if if biden wins
bradley hope and justin thank you so
much for being here authors of this
great new book
blood and oil muhammad did salman's
ruthless quest for a global power thank
you both for being here tonight
thank you thank you
coming up this week's winners and losers
in the media
see if you agree with what the editors
of mediaite have to say
you're watching the law and crime trial
network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media
as chosen by the editors at mediaite and
we're joined now by aidan mclaughlin who
is the editor-in-chief of meteorite
which like the law and crimes fraud
network
is part of the dan abrams media empire
in aidan we start this week with two
interviews one winner one loser
let's start with the winner from hallie
jackson of msnbc
grilling one of the president's aides so
as for the last
debate the 72-hour requirement to test
negative did the president comply with
that yes or no
hallie we are looking at how the
president can get out there without
transmitting the virus and that's what
we're going to that is not the question
that is do you not have an answer i just
want to be clear i know i
i again yes or no do you have an answer
and if you don't just think about time
to talk to the white house about very
important issues
so aid what did you make of her attempt
to get an answer
from brian morgenstern so we thought it
was quite remarkable
in that interview she actually asked six
times in
various ways uh this one question which
is a really important one as the white
house is sort of providing
obscure uh messaging about the
president's health last week
one of the biggest questions has come
out is when the president last tested
negative
we know that he tested positive for the
coronavirus on the thursday
after the presidential debate uh what
the white house has refused to answer is
when
the last time he tested negative before
that positive result was
now the commission of presidential
debates said that each candidate had to
be tested
before the debate which was on tuesday
but they didn't actually
enforce that it was a sort of honor
system where the campaigns had to tell
the debates
uh whether or not they had tested
positive or negative so the white house
now
not answering whether or not the
president had tested negative
uh for the coronavirus before the debate
kind of raises questions about when the
last time he tested negative was
and whether or not he was being
regularly tested so it's a really
concerning
sort of piece of misleading information
from the white house and the fact that
they're answering so much other
information about the president's health
but refusing to answer this one is kind
of a tell and it's something that hallie
jackson really expertly questioned
the white house on in that interview and
she asked again and again do you think
it's too much does she uh get too
uh serious about this in terms of going
after him again and again
no no no i think it's often
disappointing when you have interviews
where an anchor will ask a white house
official or any official for that matter
for
a question on something that's vitally
important the official will sort of
dismiss it and
you know whether or not they'll use
misinformation or dodge or whatever
and the anchor will just move on i think
that's a technique that doesn't do the
viewer any any service and questioning
about something that's important and
poking holes in the responses that are
being given
by the administration that's a really
valuable service so i think it was good
that she kept up
the questioning here and this week's
loser an interview done on fox news of
president trump let's take a look my
medical sources have told me that joe
biden had
two brain aneurysms not one but two
brain aneurysms i pray to god it's not
true
but my medical sources are solid on this
that he has had two brain aneurysms i
hope he's okay
do you believe that he should be
disclosing that
so why did you find that to be a losing
interview by maria martinola
so this is the second interview that
maria bartoramo has gotten with
president donald trump in the last week
the president has given a series of
interviews into friendly outlets he his
first interview
uh last week uh was with maria bartoromo
uh then he gave an interview to sean
hannity he gave one to mark levin
he went to russia limbaugh and then on
sunday he gave another one to maria
bartoramo
so in her first interview we actually
declared to the loser
uh on thursday for it because it was
really i mean it was an astonishing
interview the president said a ton of
uh factually inaccurate statements
floated a bunch of conspiracy theories
maria bartorono was supposed to be a
journalist nodded along she even
accused the democrats of stealing the
2016 election and said what's going to
stop them from stealing
the 2020 election citing uh voter fraud
which
you know there's no evidence that
there's widespread voter fraud she cited
that as evidence that the democrats are
going to steal the upcoming election
which is really crazy stuff for a
journalist to be saying on air
her most recent interview the one on
sunday she said she speculated that
she heard from sources inside the biden
camp
that biden had had two aneurysms
and that it was something she said i
hope it's not true but i heard that on
good authority that
joe biden has had two aneurysms now joe
biden did but
those end rooms happened decades ago uh
and they are not a secret that's being
held within the biden campaign
and that is a sign of sort of his
deteriorating health they were very
public they got reported on biden has
acknowledged them a thousand times
and the biden campaign acknowledged them
again this week after maria barack obama
floated that in her interview with trump
um so using
that to sort of tee up the president to
attack his political rival on his health
it was basically misinformation and it's
really bad that the people that are
watching
an interview with the president is
getting fed misinformation from the
journalist conducting that interview
absolutely a journalist and the host as
cheerleader
mclaughlin thank you so much for being
here as always
sure
and rhonda aiden and the people of media
really have their fingers on the pulse
of the media now
you know there's never probably been a
time in history where
reporters asking tough questions has
been so important and yes they've really
called the winners and the losers this
week
absolutely all right thank you rhonda
thanks to you for watching
us we'll see you next week and thanks to
the staff at long crime for getting us
on and off the air
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you